Okay, so here we are in our editor.
I see the bug, and our error call.
We're sending in the error message,
but we're not sending in the title and the art that we got from the user
so let's go ahead and fix that,
title, arts,
and we don't need to actually specify the QWORD parameters,
we can just pass them indirectly, title, art, error.
So we've done that, we saved the file, and let's try this again.
Let's type in a title, and we click submit, perfect.
Our text box stayed the same.
We replaced that text with nothing,
enter in some fake artwork,
we still see our error message,
and our text is preserved.
Now one thing I would like to show you,
remember we spent all that time escaping in our previous lecture,
let's type in some text here.
Okay, I'm going to submit this.
It rendered it nicely, it didn't--we didn't have any escaping issues.
Why is that?
You know we haven't dealt with escaping in this file at all.
Let me show you how that works real quick.
And the way I'm using Jinja,
it's the template language we're using by the way,
that's what's rendering this HTML.
One of the parameters it takes when you setup
it's little environment is autoescape,
and that's that autoescape = true,
which will autoescape anything we include from a variable,
which is really convenient
so you don't have to think about escaping content that comes from users
if you use autoescape, and I always, always use autoescape.
If you want to deliberately include something not escaped,
then you can--there's a method for doing that in your template
so it forces you to acknowledge that issue
whenever you want to be unsafe,
and in the default case, your just safe.